embl uh says not a question just to say
that most women fully support Men's
Health especially mental health being
given due attention which I think is
objectively just true yeah and she says
I appreciated Lawrence's apology it felt
sincere and thoughtful what a show
this all is yeah I think that's the
truth it is a show and that's very
very sad and I do feel you know actually
I do feel really sad that I've put GB
news in this position where they're now
sort of Desperately canceling everybody
um and they Angelos certainly has been
never been anything other than a
gentleman really Charming to me so I you
know it is a reciprocal relationship and
I do I have let them down in that way
which is why I apologized yesterday
because I wanted to I wasn't apologizing
because I don't I'm not trying to say
please can have my job I'm not at all
I'm apologizing because I have my own
conscience which leads on to this idea
which I actually we touched on last time
which is if we've got two sides of an
ever increasing tribal
ISM which won't speak to each other
you're going to have a fight at some
point and this is the skirmishes that
going on at the moment you know we'll
cancel them get rid of them but that
become it will become physical one day
so part of being a Christian is also to
forgive and you can't forgive unless you
ask for repentance you know and so that
was what the point of my video was was
to say genuinely to her so she
understood that it was totally genuine
that I apologize for the way I spoke to
her whilst not apologizing for the
sentiment behind what I
and I believe that the
world if we lived in a in a more
forgiving world then where forgiveness
was up was upheld as a real value was
was sexy was cool yeah rather than
canceling it which is cool well this is
why we wanted to have you on and have
this discussion uh actually and in terms
of the tribes fighting it's it's what we
are trying to do here which all what
we've always tried to do and that's why
you know we had Aaron bastani on
recently and Mark steel and I I did a
debate on the moral maze with Ash Saka
she will come on when she's got a book
out we want to bring people together and
have really good healthy conversations
uh and do them like this where you get
to see the whole person you know you
said some some things that people will
disagree with and I disagree with but
you're also a great guy and you know
when I've been around your kids you're a
great dad and you are like all of us a
rounded human being who's fallible who
makes mistakes lives on the edge as you
say and sometimes you do go too far and
you and I have had our private
disagreements on whatever but you know I
I I think it's really important to
humanize each other in that way